part two of my wide-ranging interview
with actress Roseanne Barr how should we
handle these controversies as a in other
words Samantha be she then apologized or
bill maher the stuff that he said over
the years that are pretty atrocious I
don't agree with them I always felt this
I always felt you don't like and I want
everyone watch my show but if you don't
like it you have a choice you have all
the power
my turn the dial right but we live in an
environment where it's not just disagree
it's like disagree get an opportunity
don't accept an apology and try to
destroy the other show I refuse to be a
part of that because I do believe that
in freedom of speech number one I make
my living with it number two I do
believe people make innocent mistakes
I'll be honest I listened to your
background and I read all of this stuff
about you and your background and your
mom and your dad ship with my mother
today
we've done the work that needed to be
done in my family and I'm very proud of
that and we have nothing but love now
we've understood but you know as having
experienced multiple personality
disorders fighting over that one all
right better was was that like having
voices in your head now it's nothing
like having voice as that schizophrenia
okay what do I know I'm not an expert or
at times different person waking up and
not knowing where you are how you got
there it's a loss of time it's like wow
you just disappeared like you would you
are another person and didn't know it no
memory of any of it and people will tell
you and I had multiple you know it's
called dissociative identity disorder
now I had something like four
prescriptions for glasses but I did wake
up and find myself in unsafe places and
didn't know why I put myself there and
that's just terrifying and you know I
know I no longer do that but you know my
whole life I spent it like that one time
I woke up in a truck in New York City I
don't think there's one view of Roseann
honestly that doesn't have a
family member a friend a neighbor what
mental health issue
oh Syria I think I think everybody
watching it knows somebody and what I
hear describe to me sounds scary it was
scary Sean I told ABC I don't feel that
I am in a good mentally balanced place
because I've been working like something
like just way many weeks leading up to
this yeah and going on promotion
crossing from Hawaii to New York and I
became am being dependent and a lot of
people have problems with ambien they're
not gonna joke that away but I'm one of
them and you know I'd find a house full
of Triscuits found the cheese you know
she wouldn't remember when you woke up
well I'd see it in the kitchen but you
wouldn't remember it you'd see it and
you say I must have eaten this during
this yeah eggs cracked on the wall crazy
make trying to make brownies and not
remember it no till the morning but this
is like you know ambien does that to
people
let me ask last question no why I wanted
want to keep going oh you wanna do
another thing now I forgot I'm sorry
last question I start going now what's
next all I told they'd be seeing you
guys I'll go get my meds checked you
knew you will you knew you were going to
a dark place I knew I wasn't keeping up
cuz I had this a whole other subject but
you know I don't absorb vitamins and
while I found out that I was really
depleted and that affects your mental
health you think you're doing way too
much and not getting the time that you
need no cuz I'm supposed to go to the
hospital every eight weeks and get
infusions because I don't absorb iron
and you had the vitamins and I just kept
saying I'm gonna I wanted that show I
wanted a second season so bad that I I
worked myself you know almost to the end
tell me what's next for you porn
no I'm no I really
I'm kidding what's next porn is your
headline hello no I'm just loving doing
my own stuff in my own studio want to
get back on that stage you want to call
them I do want to go back on tour yeah I
want to go on tour and do my stand-up
because my stand-up I just love them
look I love looking out there and I
don't have like I have a really diverse
audience of fans and I'm very proud of
that you know I don't just have
preaching to the converted I got all
kind of opinions and I try to unify what
what's Universal between all of us
[Music]